a historic new Congress with Democrats
sharing power is already challenging
President Trump and his Republican
supporters members were sworn in
yesterday and Democrats reelected Nancy
Pelosi to her former role as Speaker of
the House hours later the House approved
two measures to reopen parts of the
federal government that had been shut
down for two weeks the president is
holding new budget talks this morning
but he and Senate Republicans rejected
the Democrats latest proposal Nancy
Cordes is on Capitol Hill with a new
resistance from the most diverse
Congress that Washington has ever seen
Nancy good morning good morning this was
the new House Democratic majority
wanting to be on record as trying to end
this shutdown so last night they and a
handful of Republicans voted to fund
these agencies that have been closed now
for nearly two weeks the joint
resolution is passed House Democrats
flex their new political muscle as soon
as they took the majority passing bills
last night to end the shutdown during
the Senate to follow suit take yes for
an answer
open up government but the Senate's
Republican leader rejected the bills I
would call it political theater because
they do not include funding for the
president's proposed border wall you can
go out a barrier you can call it
whatever you want but essentially we
need protection in our country president
Trump spoke in the White House briefing
room for the first time ever Thursday
flanked by Border Patrol personnel I
said let's go out see the press you can
tell them about the importance of the
wall they basically said and I think I
can take the word basically out without
a wall you cannot have border security I
can personally tell you from the work
that I have done on the southwest border
that physical barriers that walls
actually work the stalemate over wall
funding cast a shadow on what was
otherwise a day of celebration for
Democrats to the Speaker of the House
Nancy Pelosi I extend to you this gavel
California's Nancy Pelosi regaining the
speaker's gavel swearing in the most
diverse Congress ever so help you God
including the two first Native American
women and the two first Muslim women
Democrats passed new rules to allow
religious head wear on the House floor
and they'll soon create a select
committee on climate change the American
people understand the urgency the people
are ahead of the Congress that Congress
must join them the party's next goal a
package of campaign finance
anti-corruption and voting reforms
Democratic leaders vowing to begin
investigating the Trump administration
right away you know it's been happening
with families separated at the border
some members want to go further and vote
on articles of impeachment against the
president this was new congresswoman
Rasheeda Talib at a gathering last night
we're gonna go in there winning some of
the most pressing problem right now how
to resolve the shutdown that has closed
federal agencies prevented garbage
pickup at national parks and forced some
furloughed workers to put off paying for
medicine and rent at some point do you
have to give the president what he wants
if only because there are hundreds of
thousands of federal workers who can't
afford to go without a paycheck the
president cannot hold public employees
hostage because he wants to have a wall
that is not effective the president has
said Mexico is going to pay for this
come on let's just anchor ourselves into
reality Mexico is not going to pay for
this wall so no the White House has
threatened to veto any funding
legislation that doesn't include that
funding for the border wall and that's
one reason why Nora one key Republican
senator predicted yesterday that this
shutdown could drag on for months and
months
it looks like Trump has met his match
Nancy thank you